all right good morning everybody I'm
king who from University of Central
Arkansas like I will speaker else to
talk about the background so I little
brief on my background my education it's
a scientific computing audiomatica
analysis and then I was in taxes for 12
years at teaching the university of
houston and did they move to arkansas
for another 13 years so what makes me
mobile arkansas it's the established
department i want to be chaired the
department so I check the department for
11 years and then what's going on I last
two years ago I begin to do real job not
to the chair anymore so can cody i love
what i did started the project working
on the python and the fell in love with
python and try to make some tools for
working on the data and analysis that's
my currently interest what I working on
so this project started realized I start
coding last year I heard a few speakers
talk about academia yeah we are not hide
way out of date we just you know
whatever tower you know working our
stuff but I really feel important is how
make our education current and then
really connect our students with the
current development I feel python is a
great way to do it so the students in my
introduction for computing class
the start with Python and then our back
tomorrow's final for them their present
to their fabulous projects just the
first semester one semester course with
spies on their create a lot of different
to use force in so it's very important
so but for today's I try to share with
you he thought lying so how many of you
actually hurt the interval competing not
many how about so that makes my
preparation good day because I spend a
lot of slides on this introduction so
what is interval computing and its
original motivation and why it should be
at least I feel should be very useful
for data analytics that's where I useful
then we talk about some technical stuff
and that module what includes so what I
intervals and what are the interval
vectors and matrices so the vectors from
the data points just attributes right
and the mattress is just data table so
then finally at the end we talk about
the pie so much the module with the
current and the development is not fully
functional as I hope all right but we do
have something we can do some little
demo here to share with you hope you
will be interested in this first of all
we're working with data so we are here
pile data data is something we want we
look we try to find it information from
it but the currently data in the
computing a mostly stored and processed
in point value we use spice and then we
record the fields and then we feel
that's what we want right in scientific
computing we used floating points and
then the most numerical data we stall
with to use follow the artery buoy 754
standard in the primary presentation so
this
kotone i just downloaded from the
actually 754 are the shoes I necessary
to bits how do we represent a number the
real number we use that you know the 23
bills to record the decimal fraction
condiment ISA and then we use the last
bit here and part u- to shoot you no
sign of the number and then we have a
debate year to represent exponents so
the exponent we use that buyers for 127
so we don't have to use a bit to request
the part of negative so then this charge
being here the number is in decimal
numbers should be point or 15 625 so so
if you're good and then okay not so good
why our number could be more digits
right so then okay let's use 64 days
once there there's a double precision
Cordova precision we try to present
number better so that's the way we get
out data studying our computer we try to
processing them well it's kind of
presentation to a whole problem with
touchy the matter because we are
regardless how many bits we use to store
a number we have to chop something off
right you have the 64 bits or whatever
it is you're mantissa you have to
something away that's okay tiny singh
the representation error rounding error
it's inevitable touchy the matter Oh
most of us feel now that matter the
little things who cares when we get the
gas station last speaker talked about it
in the palm at the pump if you notice
always they have someone yeah the two
dollars 64 cents at the nine above right
yeah cook nobody looks at can't doubt
nine but the zerg Edward a once in
a penny to their the gallon so let's
still make a surprise for their large
quantity for you that we don't care so
but do can we really don't care that so
here is a simple question we do have a
sequence first the number is one the
second one is one-third we recursively
evaluate it and then the question
simpler approach to infinity what would
be the X aim for the recursive sequence
for all of us a piece of clinic let's
get into Python so we define a sequence
and them x 0 y XY is one-third then for
carrying around two to hang we just we
don't want to put too much the 100 of
them we modulus tank and then we print
everything we put them out all right we
call the function sequence and we get
the output so here's output xk would be
something to 10 to the negative fifth
power twenty- sixth power so there would
be the 3.99 and for a ok yeah and a
fifty sixty seven day boy and there we
can see every ten we move and the
exponents verse 2 10 to the sixth power
so 1824 serious thats exfoliative right
in the de trained with the number would
be grow big and a bigger so what the
parts on tells us and I could try to ram
more we change that the parameter we
went to 50 50 become another number so
just I'll computer say I can store it I
don't know what's going on right they
either we're through you know we fix the
problem okay so for us the data analyst
with your yeah we were can only look at
the program we trust the answer right so
let's wait a minute mathematical I by
the induction you can prove that
sequence actually equivalent T
you won over 3 2 n's power as a approach
to infinity these sequences certain that
goes to 0 but what do we have the moment
ago with the shoes you keep increasing
increasing we work at infinity right
whatever language you use whatever
computer you run as a large you use the
floating-point arithmetic you work at
the sequence sometimes the positive
infinity sometimes because to negative
infinity that depends the environment
you use one review our referee up with
my purple many many years ago is that
all these eyes have actually 754 you
want have the problem as a boy with
forces back that's incorrect you know
not we running arguably 754 so what are
you different so that is a certainly a
bigger problem right okay I'm gonna let
that honest well analyze the data that
we tell you okay according to my
calculation you should the flow now all
right the other hand together everything
but looks like he's not ready to jump in
the ocean or something or the pool right
are we getting our computational results
correct Car'das trust our analysis well
we got some zim like the elephant I
caught you to my calculation yes with
the flow but yeah oh thank the matter
elephant can swim right I think yeah so
that's okay but hard some sales so the
idea for interval computing was
developed initially by professor nerima
war I also Teleki this speech to him as
well I met him I worked with him
and he passed away early this month
right here he created the idea well here
was a grad student in Stanford for his
ph.d he tried to figure that problem the
hawk computer does not give us reliable
solution the time so he proposed the
idea called interval computing if you
track the history they may have
something else talk about it but we say
the modern interval computing the idea
really started become a branch of
computing is by him from him yeah its
fundamental theorem of interval
arithmetic is so whatever function you
evaluate so what's going on if you put
these parameters or arguments as
intervals then the result should contain
all the solution you need so so that is
the fundamental theorem and his
dissertation actually it's Ordinary
automatic error analysis in digital
computation the time actually worked at
Lockheed not lock good morning the time
Lockheed that diagnosis is the villain
war and the Pentagon the one to see all
the missiles whatever so why not hit a
target so that's all the computers run
or something whatever with so the we try
to analyze his job is aha yeah the last
error automatically why don't we have to
worry about it you know duties in the
numerical analysis field it you always
try to figure out is the yogurt is mr.
ball is kind of little prada Beijing at
the beginning oh that impact final
results like this agri sequence we use
the moment ago right yeah all the little
error it cost zero to infinity
a huge difference so the basic idea is
we cannot represent a floating point
precisely but we could use two points
and the pound 8 making the interval for
example we all know pi is evident not
signika decimal it's irrational number
so nowhere to replace interpipe
precisely inside a computer so how we do
it let's use the lower bound upper bound
of balls with no prior muster in between
and the day what we do we use the
intervals in our calculation passed on
his fundamental theorem of interval
computation then we would get what the
final result would be begin unit yeah we
don't know what's going on but we just
pass cared with a basket to the
operational data and then we work at the
correct answer oh no but not precisely
we know the answer must be within in our
basket right we carry out if the basket
too big probably which into more work to
ensure to narrow the range we've know
what would be useful so here is a few
examples on the interval computational
arithmatic to the addition is easy so 1
comma 2 u + to come off three would be 3
comma 5 the lower bound at the lower
boundary upper bound is 5 so we done but
however we use the 35 we subtract the
one operand we will not get it 2 comma 3
anymore because do our subtraction your
lower bound would be what three months
to one minimum here maxima over there
anything in here could happen to
subtract into other side so with the
lower bond of a Bonneville reliable
computing de here the 14 so that is okay
there are teaching the universe of not
subtracting anymore interval
animal and then we do multiplication and
you will see you to the division aha
same thing so that is some kind of
fundamental say ye interval computing
people have tea dealers all right the
end of a computing war of course
otherwise I won't work for it for over
2,000 years ahead so here are some
awarding winning applications the
computing in chemical engineering award
of the american institute of chemical
engineering 1998 to professor mark
stutter and he also my colleague his
grad student worked on this project with
him and then the 1990s so what he found
is using the hint of all measures try to
solving some chemistry designing problem
and define some solutions for nonlinear
system never found before but that was
interval computing they found it so
that's the only award given to him in
the country near a computer in chemical
engineering award the otherwise david
robbins price of american mathematical
society the 207 award good to see me or
Ferguson and the Thomas hall the proof
of capital injection so dark injection
over 300 years old and them samuel
focusing focusing delayed and then with
his that time period PhD advisor I
believe the University of Michigan yeah
by the way mark Stoddard when he that it
is award he was in University of
Illinois urbana-champaign
and then he moved to Indiana yeah now
it's work Indiana yeah some other sins
so yeah I want to bring this up to say
okay you know what computing really
works yeah you can produce a result of
winging results okay yes how about that
example you use the moment ago that was
the interval computing we work on it we
get okay x0 is why the interval and XY
is that use the bound which interval to
bonded and we do the loop again we found
okay yeah it does not give you something
however the key was something if you
look at the lower bound is what negative
sign even though the exponent goes real
high that the high bond gives word
positive so what's that mean that means
the true answer should realize in this
interval although at the very beginning
is not much about the positive by the
way what shoes you a moment later what's
going on here all right yeah so all
right the whole idea the original idea
is what the use intervals to pound our
opera operands but our data we tried to
figure out what the final result would
be right yeah we know our answer is
wheezing some range we expect okay so
that the branch called what to the
reliable computing we reliable I tell
you what the computing results should be
the rain should be now we switch our
attention now so okay that's the
original idea so know how to use what is
useful for data analysis into the
analysis
I guess what we want probably the exact
science we try to find something
impossible you give us there that we
find a knowledge do we have one hundred
percent of like the proof of the cereal
that's answer is the perfect it's
correct no problem probably not we'll
use statistics probability we means what
we yeah looks like these you know but
possible so our signs the bottom line I
feel the probably is an inexact science
we find a computational results but it
must be verified by the real world or
what's the correct may not be always
right yeah so I have to find it so the
life cycle for data analysis my feeling
probably can start from anywhere here
okay so let's say we started from data
as most are focusing big data whatever
data we start with data and then we
crunch the data we process it whatever
way we do use right we try to find some
knowledge or information that what do we
hope that's the correct hopefully but we
don't know let's use in application
apply another application and then we
observe with the result it was correct
okay so look at data we can use it when
not right yeah data we try to figure out
what's wrong so the cycle never ends you
need that analysis cycle so what we
assume by assumption if in unsupervised
the training we assume what we do not
have any knowledge but data so what we
try to find objectives okay from the
data
we try to extract possible but not a
perfect if I met you hope it's perfect
better right yeah we hope but most
likely we may not be able to guarantee
I'll answer is perfectly correct so we
got the in precise rather than rigorous
mathematical the serum to working on all
data we do have theory right yeah but
this server itself like the regression
analysis to we guarantee the
progressions in give us the function but
mathematically it does not guarantee any
observation will be research your
progression even you with 95 99 percent
confidence even 99.99 right so a the
interval computing so what do we do we
feel fatigue analysis yeah it's not
different object from the reliable
computing it's not try to find something
perfect but you find something working
catch the information we want so we
don't have t use follow that fundamental
theorem of interval computation so in
the interval computing community people
feels more like my own feeling little
bit of religious to the serum okay well
do currency every city correct but if
you're telling yourself the incorrect
you're in precise you know the knowledge
the output you not expect the perfect it
might not be necessarily follow the
serum so what do we look at it it did we
look at the interval that due to the
type
instead of a point about the data so why
interval that are good because interval
data includes and certain day you're not
the metadata the point on a single point
you get the word some variation included
in your consideration and in real world
when we observe data our observation
most time or what an interval ranged
they are not what precise a point why
should we call them as a point why don't
we be called a maza intervals and the
more importantly use interval computing
many results are happening with indulge
the processing intel analysis i'll show
you example and also for big data it has
a potential why make that is so big
because we look them as every different
points if we use the small interval to
cover a region to repress into that one
we are now that distinguish them the
single are different the points we look
at their entire property so interval
computing yeah they sure to have some
role to play in Callanetics so to
gratitude in the work with me on these
data analysis cluster analysis the guy
some good results yeah why is published
two years ago three years ago the other
one's going to publish today dr. day
this year yeah i expect we do some the
interval body the matrix against the
decision-making system interval wise the
graphs and the Florida works and the
time series interval this square
analysis are all regression so here we
should example this
real world data is from economics we try
to analyze the data with the S&P 500 so
I'm not an economist I don't know it I'm
why buy stocks oh it's get something
really crazy right yeah so I don't want
you how to do that but one of my
colleague collaborate also in my school
he's the computational finance the
professor and then when we talk to her
that's okay I say your stock markets you
have the opening price a closing price
you have the download there hi there
should be intervals you know appointed
delete the pervert another walk and then
his work interesting one of them it's
the project predict the big economies
trained so he got data from S&P 100
years and collect we started the project
in a 205 so here so that is the the
traditional way I do it is the point so
the kadigidi prediction answer here the
years so yeah hard to see we'll see next
page and what they do they'll care use a
pointer prediction the add or subtract
the percentage of standard deviation and
then whatever so what's going on so
here's a shoe and your variation for the
HTTP 500 is lindsay's the yellow and
pink yeah so here but with that higher
mmm confidence probabilistic confidence
that's a believe in ninety-five percent
so from the previous the point solution
so we got the prediction traditional way
protocol lower bound and the upper
bounds so what's going on we can
see haha yeah the waste another five
percent confidence part of a ballistic
confidence we found the what we found it
from nineteen forty two to three let up
extra 20 for should be at the end yeah
we found that while yeah it's big really
you have it about the far away from a
real and also even we can see here the
completely missing completely missing
missing missing five companies missing
all right you are 78 years but the you
get what not many of them just come to
the missing so uh how that ninety-five
percent occurrence not much it has
another one percent right okay now i use
the interval competing crunch the same
data so here is a water week are defying
letter published several finance Geno's
all right yeah so what do we got is okay
the interval computing shoes yeah we the
lower bound actual the yellow steel or
the predicted one and that the above two
so this is the actual this our
prediction much better perfection please
hear ya what do we do here the range
here is about the less than hundred
percent you know 17 here is the negative
point of fifteen fifteen percent changes
in the lawyer let's look at the previous
one the traditional method issues what's
going on well pointer 15 hear that what
hundred fifty or something you know
here's Balu is what we're far apart
we're apart from the real so that means
the interval computing actually chula
make sense the produced real good result
with real data and in the world it works
okay so let's finish the introduction
part and then I i know we have lunch in
the few minutes right yeah so I promise
you yeah inama minutes okay our promise
or finish before large don't let you
hungry alright so here's the summary of
that example is the classical or
traditional ordinary least square the
mean error is to normalize the present
twenty percent and the instant deviation
is about nineteen percent and if we use
the confidence the interval what do we
got yeah we got something even higher
error yeah seventy two percent and then
we got that we have a actual reserve
ratio greater jihad measure the index to
show how precise answer you got accuracy
so this is the interval least square or
the wisdom me and the max just use that
lower bound upper bounded interval so we
got our admin error only a five percent
compared to what we had before and if we
wish the ninety two percent the
confidence interval that's the one point
five ten deviation so we got amla what a
five percent with the real high what the
stability our standard deviation slow
right with this is activating slow means
what on the bell curve with ruler swing
right it's good okay it's very good so
get the better answer in terms of what
high accuracy higher stability and we do
not missing anything alright so yeah the
summary on that part now we switch back
to the the interval computing okay it's
good yeah
whatever you say it's a Salesman you
shall sail into the computing right you
what you got here now what is for me so
how does it work so we moved to the
interval itself yeah intervals would
have to kind of voice with a
mathematical interval so the real
numbers well machine to vote because
it's a computer we present it must be
machinery presentable and then we have a
meter intervals so it's nothing because
interval have the dual property what the
dual property means on one side is what
it's a number operator addition
subtraction to every somatic like
everything else in the points but on the
other side intervals asset you have the
set up Reggie is the Uni intersection
you can find all of these things so yeah
if the input I said Maxim City knowledge
right yeah so no tension why should we
use the powder face the letter for
interval quality lower and score apps /
lying as a lower bound upper bound so
you had the midpoint you have these are
areas you have its ways BB presentation
you could use the low upper boundary
percentage you could use the midpoint of
areas represented and the operations you
can put it in the properties yeah here's
my operations and the automatic
operations we mentioned and we also have
additive universe specified and the the
set operations and some other operation
the comparison operators or intervals
then we have the interval of arguments
for fundamental functions like what sine
cosine
polynomial or his transcendental
functions are implemented okay and then
our skipper slides just yet you get back
here moment the letter I don't have a
few minutes yeah llege interval vectors
so we scare single interval maximum
inter list and then his operations
involved he is the definition the
mattresses with each entry of the matrix
is an interval valued and then we can do
the operation like this yes all right
okay the interval software available in
different language c++ for turn java
matlab map oh and also the our table is
17 at eight interval computing a
computation standard is expected to
approved in june this year so we voted
already with our group worked for years
and then the formal document is through
the bullet vote secondly circulation all
she's done so as it will be a standard
release expected in the last meeting
chill still expect that all right we
never know loud until it officially
published but if it's not a published
officially released by actively i would
be surprised but still i rely for who
knows until the time we know what's
going on so that's a new standard okay
so i have two more minutes yes I will do
that one yeah so the standardization is
on the interval completing the self for
the archery bully 17 a dairy queen to be
released it's the song and the other one
interval blows that's a project I worked
with jack dongarra years ago and then
included in the module I'm working out
so I also want to acknowledge the grant
i received from National Science
Foundation public money attacks right so
used always whenever you talk you have
to I also want to thank you guys and
thanks to National Science Foundation
the current status was this module
student development not a fuller but i
will show you the demo and most of sins
have shoot you on the interval and the
vector and the matrix implemented
already so hit them overseas I trying to
shoot a demo yeah
yeah how do you stop come on yeah
Healing interval so that the class so
you just three classes implemented so
let me turn around is modular test you
you know we ran this module testing so
inaccessible a dozen all the time limit
or can assure that which are test
everything so the the interval all three
classes with testing and then what I'm
trying to do now is oh come on here yeah
we can also see the documentation of it
yeah you see the module dogs uh-huh come
up yeah so dozen yeah the shoe so what's
a class has involved and how their works
all right now last I try to run that
example yeah a little reprieve that
example they'll try to make something
meaningful so I call it the sequence
this sequence that we needed an
interpreter for a version of functions
that's the way we get at the beginning
with traditional why so this wire with
interesting problem than you even know
where here is follows more serum movie
what we got is sy these yeah what I
fight
if you were to write it you gather both
x1 x1 connectivity connectivity that
makes it all right but you guys we're
not going to matter if you see what do
we got we got to the answer let's move
down never bear yeah so we know we found
it alright alright thanks for your time
and we apply one or two questions yes
question